let's do producer surprise we've done
that in a while yeah i'm with it let's
just watch some tick tocks don't steal a
virtual vape see this is one this is vr
poker
poker stars that's what it is
damn is there anything cooler than
vaping virtually with your [ __ ]
ray-bans on that's sick avatars that's
what i'm saying this is it it's already
here the metaverse is here it's right
here yeah there's no getting better than
this i hate to say it but smoking a
cigarette on there feels cool it really
does like you see the smoke come out of
the it feels like you're really smoking
well the fact that you can just like pop
it in and then you're playing cards are
you [ __ ] it's just dope oh dude this
was the funniest [ __ ] ever we could
pause this nascar attempted this they
try to bring nascar to the middle of the
coliseum by the time they put all the
run off and stuff for the cars it's
literally a parade like they can't even
race oh so they had to like go slow i
mean essentially it's just like a short
track that doesn't make any sense like
nascar's are huge but there's a [ __ ] ton
of people there no those are empty seats
oh okay
let's go this would have been better
like as a go-kart event that would have
been way more entertaining than that
[ __ ] i know most people would be
like bro nascar is [ __ ] stupid
but
old school nascar is pretty crazy you're
just perpetually going straight
basically
this one's a little bigger
this one actually pees
it's a tube and a little pack behind my
back i was operating it i was the
operator all right so that was cal
played by eric that was weirdly
appropriate for what we were talking
about talking about how um his
prosthetic penis could pee
what the hell
oh my god
oh my pov what your girlfriend starts
going crazy after you break up with her
but you remember she grew up watching
coco melon oh
it just holds up a couple of that's
funny you got to calm her down that's
definitely you had to be there tick tock
if you're listening to it trust me it's
it's funny you would have loved it yeah
pov you're at a performance heart
benefit in the hamptons
i don't know what i don't know how you
describe this [ __ ] man it's a night it's
a nightmare i don't even know what
instruments what is this sound coming
from are they playing an instrument
imagine a guy walks in there on
mushrooms
what the [ __ ] is this
my dad died a couple days ago i was
wondering if somebody could like
photoshop wings on
oh that got me oh my god that guy oh my
god we don't even need anything after
that that is literally the best one all
right though yeah all right peter boy
yeah you ever gotten like pain
in your chest a weird ass experience
this morning i was like you know like
stomach pain i was burping was like
first time i've had like pain like in my
heart no really if that's heartburn or i
think it might be the beginning of the
end i don't know dude yeah okay
might be i fell asleep i'm like
i have anxieties like you'll be okay bro
he's like i have chest pain i think he
might be dying dude i woke up on the
plane and my [ __ ] left arm was numb
that [ __ ] freaked me out oh i forgot to
tell you i got um
i did the 23andme [ __ ] and i like gave
it to somebody and they analyzed it and
told me what i'm like genetically
predisposed to oh it's like a list of
like yeah 15 things yeah i remember when
you went to the doctor and they said
your cholesterol was a little high so
you like cool it on meat and stuff like
that yeah same thing they're like you're
prone to prostate cancer so cool it on
the red meat and i was like god damn it
so you went you're like that's so many
things dude parkinson's like other forms
of cancer heart disease so you obesity
nice i think that's them just talking
[ __ ]
and maybe it's like you're prone to
being a little thick well it's like a
list of like 15 things and i was like i
just need to know they're like you have
any questions nothing was like super
above average most of it was just like a
slight increase from the average got it
so i'm not like super at risk for
anything but they i was basically like
is this list like
longer shorter for most people yeah and
they're like oh we've seen way longer
lists and we've seen way shorter lists
before and i was like what the [ __ ] does
that mean yeah thanks man appreciate it
i'm gonna go buy a rack of ribs yeah and
just smoke them